wer war am überzeugendsten wer hat
dieses duell gewonnen ich lese dass hier
einmal vor denn sie sind frisch rein
klarer sieger nach der umfrage bei den
kollegen der ard infratest
ist olaf scholz 41 prozent auf platz
zwei man kann sagen abgeschlossen
abgeschlagen armin laschet mit 27
prozent und die statisten naturgemäß auf
platz 3 annalena baerbock mit 25 prozent
ganz hinten thomas nach den statements
die sich gerade gesehen haben passt das
so ungefähr ja also so bewirbt sich um
den betriebsrat bei rewe sage ich mal
das ist
dermaßen
teilweise ebenso in dieser rheinischen
erwähnen sie mich zum vertreter der dir
zu sagen
sprecher ich werde dafür sorgen dass der
heilige geist über alle gleichmäßig
ausgeschüttet wird das hatte sowas
benefiziatenhaus und weiß das war so
trocken und dröge aber wie geht wie mir
sind wir sind vielleicht so vielleicht
passen die zu uns clausen wir sind wir
oder fünf männer an sind wir trocknen
und dröge ist das was wir verdient haben
ich hab das also dieses fazit von herr
laschet fand ich ehrlich gesagt gerade
gut nehmen wir mal die reinen staat die
habe ich auch dementsprechend
verzeichnen kann ich auch nicht anders
werden uns relativ unangenehm hier
dagegen zu reden aber wir hatten ganz
wichtigen satz gesagt ich werde sie
nicht gängeln und das ist ein signal
worauf ich eigentlich schon den ganzen
bleibt ist verrate ich eigentlich klar
ja muss man sich jetzt langsam wenn man
sich sagen dass sie nicht gegen es ist
nicht klar wenn man sich die letzten
anderthalb jahre anschaut wurden wir
dermaßen gegängelt die meinungsfreiheit
werden den schlechtesten wert seit 1953
in der meinung seiner partei
er hat ja nicht alleine regiert also
dieses ich werde aus niederschmetternde
umfrage eigentlich oder also ich muss
jetzt auch mal sagen ich glaube dass
armin laschet jetzt wir waren heute beim
boxen er hat jetzt ko schlag gekriegt
ich glaube wenn du wenn du so unter
druck stehst wenn du wenn es so auf dich
einprasselt wenn du in den medien auch
denen die ehe die eher wohlwollend
gegenüberstehen normalerweise hörst dass
du es nicht kannst wenn du
umfrageergebnis hast die immer nach
unten gehen wenn du dann in dieses duell
dass man meine frau berbalk weg rein
gehst wenn du nicht echt wahr ist aber
häufig wir sehen gerade live wenn du
nicht schlecht warst dann gehört viel
dazu jetzt noch so auszusehen weil ich
kann mir schon vorstellen dass er auch
innerlich mal zusammen sagt alles andere
wäre unmenschlich und ob das jetzt dann
noch reicht auf letztlichen radioaktiver
mit ihm zufrieden das ist doch schon mal
ist sie aber dem gespann ist völlig
recht dieses dieses dies aber dieser
satz ich werde sie nicht geändert da
muss man sagen menschenskinder
menschlich bundeskanzler wäre dann
können sie alle zeit geben seinen gästen
noch einen schönen was sie endlich
wollen was sie können
[Musik]